just stare at a wall for an hour it's
one of the most powerful meditations
that people in our community do what are
the outcomes that someone that looks at
a wall for an hour get it spans the
whole range of things some people will
like break down and cry some people will
have catharsis for some people it'll be
complete torture with no benefit it's
like a whole thing but it's just learn
to be bored you see what the running a
marathon was hard stare at this wall for
an hour at least you've trained your
muscles to run the marathon have you
trained your mind to be bored for an
hour the biggest thing that restricting
yourself from technology does is
probably does help you reset that
tolerance sum mixed bag about whether
people go through withdrawal or not some
of it could be like more of a real
Neuroscience or physiologic withdrawal
but some of it may just be like I'm used
to not being bored in my tolerance for
being bored is so low now once you can
train your mind to tolerate boredom you
no longer fall into the pull of these
things because then you don't need to
play a video game because boredom's okay